hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde golf
simulator mit mir luca und ich habe
wieder die besten szenen
zusammengeschnitten damit jetzt ein
video hat mit den besten zehn das war
eine sehr sehr lange schnitt arbeit wenn
es euch deswegen gefällt ihr mehr von
solchen videos volt drückt den daumen
nach oben und schreibt mir eventuell
auch andere spiele oder andere modi und
in die kommentare die ich auch spielen
soll oder will ich sagen jetzt viel spaß
beim video nadu wie geht's dir einen
neuen besten freund cook ihr übel dass
mein bester freund steve klink einfach
ein orgasmus schön oh ich hab gehört ein
paar sekunden zeit um so viel scheiße
wie möglich anzurichten
das sieht einfach aus sondern kann da
war die ganze zeit von so einem scheiß
trampolin hochgeschleudert wir nicht so
viele punkte machen wie möglich aber ich
krieg einfach keinen sinn
mein gott alter
einst leiter okay das ist doch mein gott
das bin ich wenn schule aus ist auf dem
weg
ich glaube dass du den sieg ein bisschen
mein okay ich nehme jetzt einfach hier
so ein verdammtes auto mit mit meiner
zunge und stellt das jetzt einfach mal
hier auf die straße und dann schauen wir
uns an was passiert ich mein okay ich
hab nur 50 millimeter junge ist in
ordnung
fakt ist ich hab keine ahnung wo ich bin
wahrscheinlich
ich weiß nicht wo ich bin ich weiß ich
bin okay das was ihr da rotes im
bildschirm sieht es kein fehler sondern
das ist immer noch meine zunge die sonne
scheine mitnimmt und wir beide gehen
jetzt rutschen zusammen weil wir sind
allerbeste freunde und mein gott da
passiert krasser als so hin
jungs ich mag dürften die autos
ok also ich weiß nicht ob man bei einem
autorennen wirklich so abgeht aber oh
mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott ich
weit mitgezogen okay okay wenn man viele
punkte kriegen willst ist glaube ich
ganz cool
aber sonst bin ich gerade ein wenig
glauben
ich habe schon immer eine verrückte
dance moves
die sitze ist unglaublich
ich muss einfach irgendwo gegen laufen
und die bricht einfach zusammen kay cool
ich habe einfach eine verdammte scheiße
blume mitgenommen und ich brauchte
länger um diese blumen zu ziehen hat
sich grünen auto gezogen haben
so gibt übrigens immer aus auch wenn ich
tanken bin ich dann einfach da rein und
dann dementsprechend komme ich auch
nicht mehr raus
doch sei kaputt hey ich liebe dich ich
verneige mich jetzt verlieren
die performance von front backflip
einfach zu schnell ich glaube ich muss
das mit space machen dass ich dann
vernünftig der der sm dass ich dann
irgendwie vernünftig landen kann also
irgendwie so neben dem moment ist
irgendwie so dass noch mal im moment
diese beine
sie sind so beweglich und zügig von hier
bin ich weiß und wann hier bin ich ein
schwarzer okay ich versuche jetzt
nochmal ich quasi vorwärts springe drehe
mich und landen dann wieder mit der
leertaste also irgendwie so ok nehmen
wir schon viel zu hoch für diese welt
ich springe einfach die anzahl drum und
knall um mich rum und alles mögliche und
irgendwie ich kann ja mal versuchen auf
den karten gleich zu springen okay okay
okay dass das etwas ist was okay mir
sagt einfach keiner dass ich hier
hochklettern kann ok nein nein aber ich
bin noch so ein blödmann habe ich schon
erwähnt dass das hier mein lieblings
waldes ich habe ihnen fremd genannten
zeit kommt überall mit hin der schwingt
immer so ein bisschen rum und der kopf
ist gar nicht verpackt okay ich sehe da
hinten dem anderen container ist dieses
feature drin mein gott du wachst voll
rum
ich will nicht dass du meine vereinte
freunde dann versucht einfach
wegzulaufen und fängt dann an zu weinen
es 53 damit einfach ein bisschen spaß
zusammen
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen trampolin
mein gott wie krass das einfach wenn
einer trampolinspringen und ich einfach
so ein mit reis und klaus einfach
überall gegen die schwingt einfach rum
wie spiderman die soll sich mal freuen
davor beide tot jetzt noch einmal diese
scheiß rutsche herunter zu rutschen aber
das ist dann richtig cool wie soll ich
denn da oben rein kommen als app die
grandiose idee gehabt mir jetzt einfach
autos zunehmen die übereinander zu
stapeln und dann kann ich auch im jahr
einspringt theoretisch
mein plan ist noch so blöd ich will
einfach autos stapeln und hier steht das
direkten trampolin davor wo mein gold
kommen hier springt da eben rein
ich habe es nicht geschafft aber egal
meine lieben freunde wenn ihr mehr von
gold simulator wollt oder von
irgendwelchen anderen spielen oder von
anderen simulationen oder anderen maps
in gold simulator oder irgendwas anderes
dann schreib mir das einfach alles in
die kommentare was ihre haben wollte und
dann bin ich sage nicht ich mir dass du
ich wenn's euch gefallen hat dann lasst
vermitteln mag ich da war das wieder
eine menge schnitt arbeit war und sonst
würde ich sagen wir sehen uns morgen
wieder in den videos und wieder ab als
auch ihr immer irgendwann anders doch
ein video von mir sehen werdet